Mathematics is a little bit like art and a
little bit like science.
One of the things that I really care about
is allowing people to access both elements
of mathematics.
On the one hand we've got this beautiful structure
that can sometimes describe the world and
sometimes describes something that we're thinking
about that doesn't have a representation in
the real world.
And on the other hand we have this powerful
set of tools that come from mathematics to
describe things that we see, information that
we process.
When people get access to that quantitative
literacy, they become powerful citizens.
They can change the way they think.
They can vote for things.
They can advocate for things.
They can make decisions about their own lives
in ways that are informed by quantitative
information.
So if we don't have information available
to us, we make poor decisions.
And it's why we as a society think it's really
important that people know how to read.
For the same reason, we think it's really
important that people have access to quantitative
literacy so they can make informed decisions
about anything involving quantitative information
— our medical care, our finances.
That also includes decisions that we make
as a society about our government and our
health care and our tax system.
So without quantitative literacy, we're driving
in the dark.
With quantitative literacy, we are powerful
advocates for ourselves and for the values
that we believe in.
I think as part of that we also get a little
access to the joy and the beauty of mathematics.